you know i always love coming down to
subaru of las vegas and telling you guys
what's going on in the community and
what they're doing with their amazing
cars but i never get to introduce you to
burton hughes himself so i want to get
to know you i want to educate everybody
about the guy behind the love here at
subaru of las vegas so
what inspired you to get into the
automotive industry and just kind of
tell us your journey before you got here
well rocky when i was 10 years old i had
an argument with god
i loved cars from a little kid i loved
cars and but my dad was a pastor and i
knew i had
um a calling to ministry as well
and and so uh i thought i had won the
argument and i went into the car
business at 19 years old but then i
ended up
studying for pastoral ministry and and i
have actually been doing both for over
30 years
and i think you know what is a minister
it's someone who serves
and so
that is the core value that i that i
lead with here and and it's really what
drives the love promise as we live it
out on a daily basis at subaru of las
vegas incredible and for those who don't
know how do you guys incorporate that
here at subaru las vegas you know we get
involved in so many great great
initiatives and you know we're right at
the back to school
time of year and so we've got
several things happening uh for for our
students for our educators but you know
what one of the things that really um
stirs my heart is you know the nevada
nevada childhood cancer foundation does
a camp every year for critically ill
children and uh and they do it at torino
ranch on the backside of mount
charleston for two weeks 200 kids that
are pretty much locked up in a hospital
get to come out and they get to just
enjoy life
and to do that every year is just an
amazing thing now how does that attitude
trickle down to your team and your
employees here at subaru las vegas you
know there were so many that signed up
for camp cartwheel it's called there are
so many i thought are we going to have
anybody left at the dealership you know
it's it's just
doing the things that we do in the
community it just spreads and we realize
giving is so much better than just
receiving we have a subaru of las vegas
read to me book drive we're collecting
new and gently used books here all
through the month of august it's gonna
go to spread the word nevada great
organization uh that we've partnered
with for for years uh and maybe just to
mention that we have partnered uh with
the marion b earl elementary school for
the month and we're gonna be uh we've
committed to giving them twelve thousand
five hundred dollars for the educators
to spend on their students you give so
much love to the community but also you
give so much love to your customers i
think that maybe you know the fact that
the inventories are extremely low but
you know what we're still uh we are
ordering cars people can special order
cars
super modus finance is actually locking
in rates if you order a car and it takes
a little longer to get and now you know
where that subaru love promise comes
from right from burton hughes thank you
for for helping our community and having
your customers leave here with safe
vehicles
and so much love thank you rocky
thank you to findlay subaru of las vegas
for sponsoring that segment find them
right there on roy horn way and for more
information just call 702-495-2100
and don't forget their special offer 2.9
financing for well-qualified buyers for
up to 48 months on select 2022 models